Today, I have followed out. We can buy Ivermectin over the color from the drug
stones. I heard a lot of good information about this drug and cancer can. We take it and what would be
the benefit. So I have been hesitant to comment about Ivermectin in the past because it's a prescription
medication most places. If you just do a Google scholarship search on Ivermectin and cancer, you'll find
that there's a number of studies that are very positive on Ivermectin and cancer. So I don't see any
problem with taking Ivermectin. The only thing I would suggest was that it is a medication and we,
you know, even though it's a long-use medication that it was initially in the market years and years
ago, very, very, very few side effects. I would still think that it would be best to close it.
It can, any medication can, you know, affect you in negative ways, but it could have very positive
effects. So I know there are some people that take Ivermectin every day, and it's like I just want to go
but why? I mean, I'm talking people who don't even have cancer. You know, so I don't know that
would suggest anything like that, but I don't see if, let's say, if you're just trying to protect yourself
against COVID or some other weird virus that may come out to pulse it might be a good thing to
have it in your arsenal might be a good thing. I do think that a lot of medications you can
become sensitive to, meaning that if you're taking it all the time, you're not going to get as
much benefit from it. And saving it, having it in your arsenal to take, let's say, if your cancer's
doing well and you're doing really well, then I don't know that I would change that and take that.
Or if, you know, you don't have a virus and you're feeling well, it might be good to have it in
your arsenal if you do need to take it. But I think it is, obviously it had
red-edged down. But now that it's successful at COVID, that's why they abandoned it.